okay okay we're ready
hi everyone and welcome to electric
shock chess the rules are simple it's
going to be me against ass guild and we
have these uh electric
these electric shockers
uh we're wearing them we'll be playing a
chess game and magnus is the judge if he
doesn't like our moves he's gonna try
and shock us
good luck
are you feeling the pressure yeah yeah
definitely it's a key moment i know
what's going on oh
key moments
[Music]
okay so what to do
[Music]
[ __ ]
that was for bishop b6 yeah that's the
picture it was an awful move
you should go there
oh okay
[Music]
the key moment
[Music]
oh okay yeah that's the point it's been
so kind to me so far
come on
oh nice yeah
ow
it's getting rough yep if you get
smothered mate i'll pump it up to 16.
[Music]
that was pure sadism
it's allowed i make the rules
oh that's bad
[Music]
come on brinski one trick
[Music]
good game oh you're getting there
i need to learn to scream more manly
i need a proper one for for losing
how much was it
let me hit me
currently 45.
[Music]